i wonder if we can make a time capsule
if you're talking about truly preserving
our essence you need some motion to it
we're gonna bury this thing and we're
gonna get preserved for eons we're never
ever gonna die
i was thinking about like time
history the fact that we're always
finding physical objects you know from
past eras and learning about them in
this day and age what's going to be left
of what we do for the generations that
come next people's likenesses now are
being scanned in their very essences are
being scanned for all of history imagine
a thousand years being able to pull up
perfect captain america right now it's
only the elites that have access to this
essentially immortality guys if you scan
your essence you're immortal it's not
freaking you you're just a freaking like
a a t pose that's all you are as a t
pose like all i'm saying is we still got
hammurabi you know in our pocket what
about us what about
i wonder if we can make a time capsule
we're not elites we're not we're not
a-list actors or anything but we got
some skills we got some computers
we got some some technology we got some
essences to preserve if you're talking
about truly preserving our essence you
need some motion to it like you can't
just be like
oh that's clint it's like not really but
it's like i'll do a garbage flip that's
plenty do you think we should put on
some motion capture and capture our the
essence of our movement we could record
some audio with that mocap get the voice
in there too really capture the full
essence of the person like you need to
record every single vowel and consonant
sound possible so that people can mix
that in the future and whatever they
need wait but how i mean even if we put
our essence on a flash drive
and bury that the flash drive is going
to go bad at some point anything that is
stored with any sort of like magnetic
writing those magnetic fields weaken
over time so they could you know die
what's the most high-tech way to store
these files like how do we future-proof
this there's this format called an
m-disk it's basically a blu-ray disc
with a special coating that will last 1
000 years
right what dude we need to get one of
those can you put that into a disk drive
on your computer yes it should be
compatible with pretty much any blu-ray
player and burner that's a thousand-year
arc for us to live dude that's our home
for the next thousand years what we also
should do is maybe put them in a faraday
cage so that anytime there's like an emp
or a solar flare what did you just say
faraday cage it's basically just a cage
that is able to block electromagnetic
waves a microwave for instance is a
faraday cage let's just say like a solar
flare happens and it comes down and
burns all electronics on earth or if
nuclear bomb goes off and you're just
far enough away not to get burnt put
your electronics in your microwave and
it will save them that microwave sucks
microwave let's use the microwave thank
you dude do we have a trench shovel do
we have like do we have a trench shovel
that should take such a big hole
at least this deep
we're going to bury this thing and we're
going to get preserved for eons we're
never ever going to die i don't know
about that but all right so you go get
your camera we'll meet you upstairs on
the roof let's get to scanning
today's the perfect day for doing 3d
scans because it's all gloomy you get
the ambient lighting no directional
shadows these light stands allow us
to hold a perfect t-pose and ensure that
our hands don't waver this is the
easiest way to make us do whatever you
want all right i'm ready
glass is on or off
yeah
you want a hat on clint you want that
hat the hat's part of the vibe dude this
is what's gonna go down in history as
the the peak of male fashion in 2020. if
we have you guys in the background
moving around it's gonna throw off the
scans they're gonna have to be all
behind me moving with me so we're gonna
do a little uh choreographed dance we go
y'all let's do it
[Music]
all right i'm dizzy
all right i'll do you
[Music]
all right
nick time
[Music]
okay so i checked out all the best buys
in the city none of them have the m-disc
that we're looking for so i'm gonna have
to actually buy m-disc dvds but what it
means is that i also have to buy an
m-disc burner but i did find one for 30
bucks and that should come tomorrow
add the cart with a thousand-year disk
we are actually legitimately preserving
our 3d models for the next eon yeah as
long as the crust of the earth doesn't
like explode you know yellowstone okay
so we we've all just been scanned so now
it's up to you to actually throw them
through reality capture to turn them
into 3d models so you don't know what
rigging is right when you get the 3d
model out of the photogrammetry software
it's just like a static mesh
and you give that static mesh a skeleton
and we can do this process that's mostly
automatic to connect the mesh to the
armature then when we apply motion
capture data to the armature it distorts
the mesh along with it i got to decrease
the resolution of the meshes so they're
not as taxing on the computer to animate
with them and remove all the little
artifacts from the 3d scanning so got a
bit of work ahead of me peter you got to
stop messing around we gotta get these
things
ow ow
again
what you got fossilized data is this the
stuff this is the stuff already all
right that was fast
m disc although i got dvds and not
blu-rays
and i also got a
dvd writer so once we get our scans
completely ready i'll be able to burn it
onto a disc and it will last for 1 000
years and i want to talk about why this
will last that long
most discs right are made out of like a
polymer resin of some sort and you know
they're easy to burn they're easy to
make and they last at least 15 years
this disc on the other hand is rated to
last a thousand years actually it's just
the coating on the outside that's ready
to last a thousand years the actual data
itself should be able to last ten
thousand years
it's basically made out of some sort of
glossy carbon type material it's like a
hard rock type material kind of like
diamond imagine like poor man's diamond
and that's kind of what these discs are
made out of so this is going to be our
digital tune this can't be affected by
emps or solar flares there's no reason
to put this disc inside of the microwave
however in the future people might not
even know what this thing is so you
can't just like bury this in the ground
and assume people are going to be able
to read it
so that's why we have to include the
actual dvd reader as well and this thing
could be fried by a solar flare so this
is why we are keeping the microwave
so right now i'm setting up the rococo
motion capture suit so we can stream our
body movements straight into blender to
smack them on our cg characters videoing
ourselves that's dumb that's stupid why
would we take a video of ourselves when
we could actually get 3d motion capture
alright so everyone's going to go up you
need to do a couple things to give your
guys's like essence because when people
open this thing up in like a million
years they need to know who each one of
us actually are so you guys have to do a
walk cycle we'll do a like a standing
idle like you know how do you how do you
stand around all you guys are standing
differently look at this right now look
at this totally natural run that's how
you stand
everyone's unique and you guys need to
show that like this is our chance to
show that and then you have to do uh 30
seconds to describe your entire essence
and like your whole life
30 seconds to sum up our entire essence
guys we don't have a lot of time right
we're all very impatient as is
in the future they'll be even more
impatient so you only have 30 seconds to
describe your entire life's essence all
right and i will be timing you
and i'll make sure you know when the
timer is done this is like my life and
my future are we allowed multiple takes
here we only get one take we have so
much time to do this this is gut essence
so the first take of this will probably
most likely be the most natural i'm kind
of nervous i'm kind of nervous
i know one thing my idol pose i have to
have terrible posture because i have
terrible posture this is this is the
last walk cycle you'll ever do for the
rest of your life so you might as well
get the most out of it i'm ready to go
let's do this you have 30 seconds your
whole essence everything literally
anything that you don't say
gets erased
[Music]
we're just doing like a normal walk
right
i mean whatever you want
like you're literally walking i don't i
don't i'll tell
30 seconds go oh god uh so uh my name is
ren i am a big fan of science and and
one wheels and drones and
transformers why did i say i don't know
why i said transformers but i liked oh
did you just hit my butt here
15 seconds um i would like to thank uh
my wife i would like to thank my dogs i
would like to thank everyone i've ever
met in my life
it's my gate
[Music]
all right go for it 30 seconds go hey
i'm nick welcome to my tomb uh yeah i
work here i do a lot of video stuff i've
been i had a good life working at
corridor you know with my friends over
here made a lot of videos
i i do this a lot
that's pretty common common one i like
history it's kind of funny because i'm
part of it now uh but yeah let's see i
used to i used to fence what
[ __ ] okay
i'm just gonna do my lunge
that was a pretty good lunge
i won a tournament once so yeah you
might not know what fencing is
[Music]
what's up guys my name is clinton jones
i love doing martial arts i was nine
when i started i did it for 10 years i
took drawing class every year in high
school and in middle school um i'm sorry
i almost died one time with nick we
almost died on our way on the five i
work at quarter do i do vfx i direct i
write
i can do sound design when i have to but
i don't like doing it i love kevin
suzaki
mom i love you too and dad my brother
dude love you man um
um
uh kim i mean we're about to get married
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up my name is peter france
i'm a filmmaker and a musician and i
work here at corridor digital it's a
great place i want to give a shout out
to my boys nick clint ren and jones
and
my favorite animal was the raccoon and i
uh
my dream is to be a future filmmaker i
want to make movies that are funny but
also true and i want to help people deal
with depression and also my lifetime
dream is to hike the pacific crest trail
in a thru-hike
got to keep my terrible posture all
right life essence go
well my name is dean and uh you know you
probably don't care about that
but what you might care about is this i
moved around a lot growing up
and i met a lot of people
and by meeting a lot of people i learned
one thing
that we're all the same
and so if you're a person in the future
wondering what people in the past were
like just now
we're just like you
[Music]
well that was it we all got captured
that 30 seconds went by so fast that was
not long it's kind of like life it is
like life it's over before you even
realize it okay so we've just finished
our motion capture we've finished our
little tomb intros but we need more
assets to give to the future people so
they can recreate our voices faithfully
yes we got the mocap now we need to get
the ah cap
audio cap the vocab the vocab vocab whoa
so basically every word consists of a
few different sounds that the human
mouth can make and i think if we just
say all those sounds individually people
from the future will be able to piece
together the right chunks of sounds to
create new words so we need vocab and we
need every possible sound ever
[Music]
ready
[Music]
oh
darn yes no
maybe
[Music]
apples bananas pears peaches
strawberries
absolutely tomorrow yesterday before
then
visit the next toyotathon
[Applause]
[Music]
literally everything
that we could have said
right then and there now that we've
recorded all the mocap we even got some
vocab in there the next step
oh yeah that's some good material right
there we just got to be really careful
ren for power and sewage lines because
if we rupture a line
yep
[Music]
it's a really good hole
[Music]
perfect that's perfect perfect all right
now we gotta actually go finish what we
gotta preserve
so we've managed to get everything done
peter got this massive render out
everyone cranked super hard to get all
of the stuff onto the drive i think this
will really capture and introduce us to
the next generation of humans on earth
who find this time capsule i'm really
excited i forgot to like thank my family
and stuff but besides that i feel pretty
preserved i'm glad i got my lunch in
there yeah i feel adequately preserved i
feel like that sums up me 100
flawlessly yeah you know got the
childhood in there i got shout outs to
the fam i didn't get shout outs to like
all my best friends so i definitely feel
bad about that i wish i'd had some more
time to prepare because i wish i had
thanks like my family and stuff but i
feel like the natty performance is more
genuine so i feel like i was pretty
accurately preserved rent is the disc
burned
hot off the presses
got our time capsule we got the player i
also have a spare disc in case they want
to make a backup for whatever reason so
the idea is that we're putting this
stuff in a plastic container to keep the
moisture out for years to come in fact
nick has a special item oh yeah so we
have our hieroglyphics to explain what's
going on
you dig up the microwave out of the hole
you get the dvd in the player this plus
that
plus computer
equals enlightenment lastly we have like
some silica gel that i got from some
korean beef jerky and that
you know this will keep the inside of
this container moisture free it'll
absorb all the moisture
i will meet you guys here what's the
year 20 20 20. i'll meet you guys here
20 50. 2015. we'll meet you guys here
and just to check on our files and see
how they're doing maybe we grew beards
in our 3d renders
[Music]
all right this is the moment of truth
let's put the box in the microwave the
emp blast shield
sealing it inside
the emp blast shield
[Music]
all right looks good all right uh you
guys want to get some lunch yeah let's
do it
thanks for watching i highly recommend
you check out quarterdigital.com you get
early access to all the content we throw
on youtube before it ever goes live
there plus you get 15 off merch the
vlogs are back you can see them there
quarterdigital.com i highly recommend
you check it out next week we are trying
to make birdemic kind of good stay tuned
for that and subscribe